die zukunft steht auf dem spiel die eu
will sie retten treibhausgase runter ein
klimaneutrales europa im expresstempo
der green deal soll die klimawende mit
millionen an öffentlichen und privaten
geldern lenken auch deutschland steht
vor einem umbruch als größtes
industrieland der eu mit dem höchsten
co2 ausstoß beim verkehr in der
industrie und bei der energie ich reise
dahin wo sich alles ändern soll packen
wir das
ich kruse in einem brandneuen
spitzenprodukt unserer autoindustrie und
verbraucher im schnitt
11,7 liter sprit
was für ein red mein modell ist von 2020
dem europaweit heißesten jahr der
wetteraufzeichnung nicht lange her da
bewarb mercedes autos wie dieses noch
als nonplusultra für den
großstadtdschungel
ist das verbrenner konzept heute noch
zeitgemäß
bei mercedes sagen sie der verbrenner
sei ihre cash machine da hätte ich gerne
nachgefragt doch zeit für ein interview
haben sie leider nicht schade
ab nach berlin zum top verband der
autoindustrie bei deutschlands mächtiger
auto lobbyisten hildegard müller frage
ich nach
das aktuelle modell ist schon durch
neuere typen abgewickelt unserer
modernen auto ist noch ein
vorgängermodell aber das ist ja das
ist nicht den gibt eine neue aber es ist
ja immer so dass produktlinie neu in den
markt gehen und andere dann schrittweise
rausgehen da haben wir auch viele
bestands auch das waren 1,5 milliarden
verbrenner fahrzeuge im bestand für die
wir eine lösung finden müssen wenn wir
den klimaschutz ernst nehmen deshalb
brauchen wir zum beispiel synthetische
kraftstoffe auch vielleicht auch ich
fakt ist die verbrenner spülen gerade
satte rekordgewinne in die autokonzern
kassen und ich habe das sichere gefühl
dinosaurier fahrzeuge werden wir mit dem
green deal zurücklassen müssen
[Musik]
die autoindustrie verpasse gerade die
ausfahrt sagt mir die energie
wirtschafts expertin claudia kemfert sie
schlägt eine ganz andere zukunft vor
ganz ohne private autos
in der stadt brauchen wir eine mobilität
so wende hin zu einer menschengerechten
mobilität also weg vom individual auto
hin zu mehr pnv fahrradverkehr
postverkehr die ganzen stets zeuge die
wir in den städten haben die im schnitt
23 stunden am tag herum stehen und
wertvolle fläche kosten von parken bis
zur infrastruktur das den menschen
zurückgeben mit grünflächen spielplätze
und auf dem land bietet sich an auch die
digitalisierung zu nutzen
mobilitätsdienstleistungen in der
kombination mit elektromobilität wo man
auch möglichkeiten schaffen kann zu
laden bedeutet dass arbeitsplatzabbau in
eine auto branche und massive einbrüche
wenn sie es so gut machen bedeutet es
nicht arbeitsplatzabbau und in der
zukunft wird es darum gehen fahrzeuge
intelligent zu gestalten
mobilitätsdienstleistungen anzubieten
das heißt man hat eine app man will von
a nach b kommen ist gar nicht mehr
selber eigentümer eines fahrzeugs
sondern nutzt ist nur vielleicht
gemeinschaftlich und insofern ist die
zukunft der mobilität eine ganz andere
als wir heute kennen um deutsche
treibhausgase bis 2030 sogar um 65
prozent unter das niveau von 1990 zu
bringen müsse viel mehr verkehr auf die
schiene
doppelt geimpft setze ich mich in ein
leeres abteil der bahn die wirbt seit
einiger zeit darum endlich viel mehr
güterverkehr aufs gleis zu setzen
die politik sagt es
menschen sagen es weil sie wollen dass
es vorwärts geht also tun wir doch
einfach was alle seit jahrzehnten
ich fahre richtung schweiz dort wurde
vor jahrzehnten lkw verkehr auf die
schiene verlagert auf eine strecke quer
durch die alpen
2016 war mit dem gotthardtunnel der mit
57 kilometern längste eisenbahntunnel
der welt fertig
2020 folgte als letzter der chenery
tunnel im tessin
eine güter verbindung von den großen
nordsee häfen wie rotterdam
quer durch deutschland und die alpen bis
nach genua zum mittelmeer das war die
vision
nur der schweizer teil ist fertig der
deutsche leider noch lange nicht
in basel treffe ich einen derjenigen der
sich das damals mit ausgedacht hat
benedikt weibel der ex chef der
schweizer bahn und der rheinhäfen
erklärt mir wie die schweiz die kurve
gekriegt hat sie in der nacht fahrverbot
vordergründig wegen lärm aber im grunde
ist es eine protektionistische pass hat
muss man sagen
und dann haben wir die die
leistungsabhängige schwerverkehrsabgabe
die war unglaublich wichtig es war
eigentlich in der ganzen diskussion um
die außenterrasse saale peceny streicht
dieses geld hat man auch gebraucht zur
finanzierung der diese autos versammlung
dh sie haben geld und wunder vom
straßenverkehr umgeschichtet
der schiffverkehr weil auch himmel klar
war das natürlich man dadurch auch die
straßen massiv entlastet also dem senden
haben natürlich autofahrerinnen und
autofahrer eine hohes interesse dass
diese lang häufige schwerverkehr zu
einem wesentlich teil auch auf der
schiene feder nicht nur auf den
autobahnen
pro kopf gibt die schweizer bahn fünfmal
mehr für schienenwege aus als die
deutsche bahn
weibel hofft nun dass wenigstens neue
techniken mehr verkehr auf die schiene
bringen
ich meine das hab ich gelernt bei der
eisenbahn was die kapazität extrem für
mäntel sind geschwindigkeit differenzen
schnelle züge langsamer züge auf dem
gleichen netz also wenn sie die
geschwindigkeit harmonisieren
dann haben sie dann erhöhen sie die
kapazität
das spielt uns jetzt natürlich auch die
ganze entwicklung in der digitalisierung
in die hände mit mit sensorik mit
kameratechnik mit künstlicher
intelligenz auf deutscher seite
verzögern planungs schwierigkeiten
bürgerproteste und wohl auch mangelnder
politischer wille den ausbau frühestens
2041 glaubt die bahn ag den deutschen
strecken schluss für den schnellen alpen
verkehr zu schaffen gerne hätte ich
nachgefragt warum so spät doch leider
hat man dort keine zeit für ein
interview
[Musik]
mein fazit
ausgerechnet beim verkehr geht es in
deutschland eher langsam voran wie sieht
es in sachen green deal bei der
industrie aus ich besuche das
zweitgrößte stahlwerk deutschlands bei
salzgitter das allein schon rund ein
prozent aller deutschen co2 emissionen
ausstößt
hier war ich schon einmal 2009 10 schon
damals wollten sie die riesigen
stahlhofen bald statt mit kohle und koks
mit sogenanntem grünen wasserstoff
befeuern grünen weil er aus mit
windkraft erzeugten strom gewonnen wird
sein können sie in salzgitter ihr
klimaprojekt neue stahl höfen sollen mit
wasserstoff laufen und nicht mehr mit
kohle erdgas wird ein zwischenschritt
sein müssen sagen sie hier denn die
frage sei wie schnell bekommen sie große
mengen grünen windstrom für ihre riesige
produktion es hilft mir nichts wenn ich
hier meine meines alters anlage stehen
habe auf dem offenen meer einen
offshore-windpark begleiter dazwischen
fehlt dann habe ich mit zitronen
gehandelt also werden wir uns dem ganzen
auch gemeinsam mit den netzbetreibern
aber auch mit der politik die kann hier
sich nicht aus affäre ziehen ja sowohl
die kollegen in berlin als auch auf der
landesebene als auch in den kommunen der
monster einfach aufstellen müssen wir
tun alles was wir können um der politik
klarzumachen ihr müsst euch schnell
bewegen schaffen wir das dann bis 20 30
es wird langsam zeit dahin ganz offen es
wird langsam zeit also den offshore
windpark zu planen von tag eins bis
inbetriebnahme sind irgendwas zwischen
sieben bis zehn jahren dann sind es
schon fast zu spät dann sind wir dann
sind wir ende der 20er so netz zu bauen
wissen wir auch braucht auch seine zeit
wir haben klaren plan hier wir können
2005 20 26 hier an der an diesem
standort mit grünem stahl starten ja
aber ich mir brauchen sicherheit ich
kann keinem aufsichtsrat der welt kam
aktionär der welt erklären wir gehen
jetzt mal 1,4 milliarden euro aus was da
am ende des tages rumkommt machen sie
die stahlkocher in salzgitter wollen
planungssicherheit
fossile energieträger kohle gas öl
werden bislang in deutschland mit
mindestens
37 milliarden euro jährlich
subventioniert von diesem privileg über
kerosin steuerbefreiung bis hin zu
emissionsrechten für die industrie der
green deal der eu könnte stattdessen
klimafreundlichere anlagen fördern
ich fahre richtung münchen auffallend
windräder sehe ich in bayern so gut wie
keine auch aufgrund strenger
abstandsgebot wurden 2020 ganze drei
anlagen beantragt die klimawende
brauchen überschaubare klare regeln
fordert der präsident des renommierten
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung ifo
clemens fuest
wir brauchen keine planwirtschaft es
soll also nicht so sein dass die politik
entscheidet in welchen bereichen jetzt
investiert wird um grüne technologien zu
entwickeln sondern das muss schon die
industrie ton beim green deal der eu
wird mit einer einstufung bewertet wie
klimafreundlich investitionen sind
taxonomie nennen sie das clemens fuß
geht das zu weit
denn man will die gesamte
wirtschaftliche aktivität danach
klassifizieren ob sie nachhaltig ist
oder nicht da kommen jetzt viele
lobbygruppen die natürlich dann als
nachhaltig klassifiziert werden wollen
meines erachtens schadet das unter
umständen mehr als es nutzt das ist
nicht das zentrum der klimapolitik das
findet woanders statt nämlich beim co2
preisen bei der beförderung
klimafreundlicher technologien bei der
errichtung von infrastruktur
darauf sollte der staat sich
konzentrieren
green deal wirtschaft nach plan macht
das sinn
noch wird viel investiert im co2
intensive bauprojekte aus beton wie
diese milliarden teure stadtautobahn
erweiterung mitten durch berlin
die kalkgrube lägerdorf bei hamburg kalt
ist die basis für das beton bindemittel
zement um zementwerke wie dieses
klimafreundlich umzubauen brauche es
staatliche hilfe und geld aus dem
finanzmarkt die green deal taxonomie mit
ihrer einordnung nach
klimafreundlichkeit könne da helfen sagt
mir holz in deutschland chef torsten
hahn diese transformation die wir hier
in deutschland vollbringen müssen die
wird sehr viel kapital brauchen und da
ist es natürlich auch wichtig dass
dieses kapital den weg findet an die
richtigen stellen und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz gutes lenkungsinstrument diese
taxonomie dass dies aber auch für sie
dass in gewissen druck haben gute
produkte zu haben wir können natürlich
nicht irgendwelche luftnummern
produzieren sondern wir müssen natürlich
dann produkte haben die am markt auch
bestehen also es muss eine grüne rendite
gehen das gesamte co2 auffangen und mit
grünem wasserstoff aus der windenergie
verarbeiten das wäre ein erster schritt
nicht nur zu klimaneutralen zement sagt
torsten hahn sondern zu ganz neuen
weiteren produkten
das heißt dass wasserstoff kommt dann
hier an und die das co2 und daraus wird
dann mit hanno gemacht mit dem methanol
kann ich dann in die raffinerie gehen
kann dann zum beispiel grüne kraftstoffe
wie kerosin für die flugindustrie machen
ich kann aber auch weiter ohne viele
herstellen und dann bin ich in der
kunststoffindustrie
green deal hieße hier neue produkte neue
geschäftsmodelle so der plan denn
aufgeht
so das ist schon wie die reise zum mond
wir müssen aufgrund des zeitdrucks denen
wir haben müssen wir ganz viele dinge
parallel entwickeln dh wenn wir
gleichzeitig dieses projekt in diesem
industriellen maßstab stehen haben
wollen dann müssen wir unser zementwerk
umbauen wir müssen in einer offshore
wind genügend haben wir müssen methanol
aufbauen wir müssen die elektrolyse
anlage bauen von einer großen dimension
und wir müssen die ganze pipeline
infrastruktur schaffen und das ganze
muss parallel laufen damit wir dann
irgendwann auch sagen können 20 27 28
wie du schneiden das rote band
prima wäre weniger oder schon
vorhandenen beton zu nutzen wie geht das
ich fahre zum stillgelegten flughafen
berlin tegel ein beton eldorado der 70er
bald soll hier ein klimafreundlicher
neuer wohn- und ausbildungsort für die
aus den nähten platzende hauptstadt
stehen eine stadt in der stadt mit
fußläufigen wegen die wohnen ausbildung
arbeiten erholen und produktion
verdichtet
ich treffe den geschäftsführer des
projekts philippe de der bald mit seinem
team loslegen will
die vorne stehen dann die
industriehallen und dahinter gewerbe
forschung da drüben sie mit den han land
der rest dahinter wird wirklich der
natur bleiben und dann auf der anderen
seite das wohngebiet mit dass schumacher
quartier mit seinen 56 1000
wohneinheiten aus holz für 12.000
menschen das größte holzbau quartier der
welt größere biodiversität hinterher als
vorher was blüht blüht was an beton
steht bleibt im zentralen sechseck des
flughafen hauptgebäudes soll eine
hochschule einziehen
hier könnten bald studierende
herumschwirren die nachnutzung ist für
das klima weit sinnvoller als abriss und
neubau
auch der alte lufthansa hangar cannstatt
für flugzeuge als ausbildungsstätte
genutzt werden für eine feuerwehr
akademie den beton auf dem vorfeld würde
bouffier am liebsten aufbrechen und
recyceln aber dafür fehlt die
gesetzliche grundlage
diese probleme die müssen wir lösen und
zwar grundsätzlich wir müssen ran wenn
wir kreislaufwirtschaft ernst meinen
dann muss es durchdacht sein bis zum
beamten der die der den stempel
hinterher runtersetzen müssen der kann
gar nicht anders im augenblick als es
abzulehnen und das ist nicht seine
verantwortung oder ihre verantwortung
sondern des gesetzgebers
um dennoch hier einen möglichst
klimaschonenden weg zu gehen soll das
neue wohnquartier großteils aus holz
konstruiert werden
wenn wir also das klima retten wollen
dann müssen wir im großen maßstab wieder
co2 der atmosphäre entziehen bäume
entziehen der luft das co2 lagern es im
holz ein wenn der baum aber stirbt im
zerfallsprozess umsetzungsgesetz das
wieder frei deswegen müssen wir ihn
ernten bevor er stirbt und es dauerhaft
wieder in gebäuden ein lager mit
dem größten holzbau quartier der welt
wollen die quartiersentwicklung hier
also ein zeichen setzen das wäre ja mal
was
[Musik]
rund 75 prozent unseres
energieverbrauchs kommen heute noch aus
öl gas und kohle der energiesektor stößt
dabei so viel co2 aus wie kein anderer
in kaum einem anderen land wurde soviel
braunkohle abgebaut wie in deutschland
ich treffe die sorbische pfarrerin hat
wieder mal in die die sorgen der
menschen ihr kennt nicht nur der
landschaftsverbrauch auch die nackten
zahlen erschüttern den glauben an die
kohle schon heute ist eine
kilowattstunde strom aus braunkohle
sogar ohne ökologische folgekosten
weitaus teurer als eine aus wind oder
solarenergie
[Musik]
ein rasch steigender co2 preis würde das
schnell verschärfen und die kohle noch
unattraktiver machen
das merken sie längst auch hier
ich denke die meisten leute kommen ins
zweifeln und merken auch selbst
mitarbeitende im braunkohle betrieb oder
also die merken es verändert sich etwas
kurzarbeit derzeit und ich denke bis 20
38 denkt ihr fast keiner mehr dass es
soweit kommt dafür dass stehen die
zeichen einfach
ganz anders
mal links landeskirche hat sich ein
eigenes klimaschutzprogramm mit eigenem
abgabensystem gegeben sie will heizungen
umstellen strom selbst erzeugen und
kostenlos an die bürger abgeben auch
hier wollen sie ein zeichen setzen wir
selber schaffen dass mit eben
dezentraler energieversorgung wir selber
alsdorf als dorfgemeinschaft als
kirchspiel haben unsere
energieversorgung und bauen die nach und
nach auf und darin sehe ich absolut die
zukunft
dass die kohle ein auslaufmodell ist das
längst eine neue zeit anbricht ist auch
hier fielen klar
warum nur hat die politik so lange
gebraucht den weg zu bereiten
in ihrer heimatstadt münster willich
svenja schulze danach fragen sie ist als
bundesumweltministerin politisch für den
klimaschutz mit verantwortlich
[Musik]
man weiß dass es teuer wird wir später
wird damit ein steigen der klimawende
aber ist dass nichts passiert warum es
gab einfach unglaublich viele blockaden
viele haben gedacht sie könnten sich
noch herausstellen und deutschland
müsste im klimaschutz nicht so viel
machen und jetzt müssen wir umso
schneller werden weil wir sind ja auch
eine exportnation uns wird nicht möglich
sein die ganzen veränderungen alleine
dem markt zu überlassen weil der markt
baut keine autobahn-maut keine
ladesäulen auf der wirklich für eine
wasserstoff-infrastruktur das will kann
man das beschleunigen blitzschnell ist
jetzt vollkommen klar es muss was
passieren man kann nicht darauf warten
dass die anderen mal anfangen und
irgendwann macht man selber was sondern
alle müssen mitmachen dem austrieb
energiewirtschaft sich jeder einzelne
über den gebäuden beim heizen die
landwirtschaft für alle ist jetzt
vollkommen klar es geht los
der green deal der eu wird uns mit
staatlichen vorgaben mit anreizen und
einem großen plan bei der klimawende
beine machen hier werden alte
gewohnheiten ablegen müssen ob verkehr
industrie oder energiewirtschaft die
techniken und konzepte zur umsetzung
sind da die zeit drängt endlich das
große ganze in den blick zu nehmen
[Musik]